[موسيقى]
حقق عام 2022 خمسة فائزين رئيسيين لأول مرة
ودراما كثيرة
، كما رأينا ظهور
قوة عظمى محتمَلة في لعبة الجولف
مع 10 بطولات كبرى ،
أصبحت أنيكا سورنسون اسمًا مألوفًا
وبطلة في بلدها الأم
السويد والآن جيل جديد من السويديين
بدأ اللاعبون بالسيطرة على
المباراة الأوروبية
لين غرانت ومايا ستارك أنهوا المركزين الأول
والثاني في ترتيب الجولات الأوروبية للسيدات في
ترتيب الاستحقاق هذا العام
بسبعة انتصارات بينهما في عام 2022
بما في ذلك انتصار صنع التاريخ في
الدوري الاسكندنافي المختلط حيث
أصبح غرانت الأول.  امرأة ستفوز في جولة موانئ دبي
العالمية
في ذلك الأسبوع وخلال
تلك الأيام من الواضح أنني كنت
أتنافس على الفوز الذي كنت
أفكر فيه وفكرت في اللعب
في العام الماضي ، يا إلهي ، سيكون الأمر رائعًا
إذا فازت امرأة  لأن تحقيق هذا الفوز
يعد أمرًا هائلاً بالنسبة لي شخصيًا وأعتقد
أنني مجرد إعلامي وقد
بدأ ذلك الأسبوع ولم
أتوقع ذلك وأعتقد أنه إذا نظرنا إلى الوراء
لقد أدركت الآن أنها كانت صفقة كبيرة
، فلنتحدث معك ،
كيف ستفكر في صديقك لين
الموسم ، يا للعجب لقد نسيت حتى عدد
المكاسب التي لم تحصل عليها لأنني أعتقد أن
لديك الكثير ثم نعم بقيت للتو
قويًا طوال العام ، شعرت
وكأنك لست مضطرًا لأن تكون متقدمًا ، إنه
مجرد لاعب غولف جيد
يمكنك الفوز به حتى في ليست أفضل أسابيعك
، أتمنى لو كان لدي هذا الصاعد ،
لقد بدأت موسم LED الخاص بك
مع  انتصارات في العام الماضي ، لقد
حصلت على ثلاثة انتصارات هذا العام ،
كيف تقيم هذا الموسم
، لقد كان قطارًا سريعًا للغاية ،
ارتفاعات عالية جدًا ، منخفضة جدًا ، أعني أن
الآخرين ينظرون فقط إلى
النتائج الجيدة وينسون ذلك.  لقد عانيت
أيضًا من الكثير من التخفيضات في هذا
النوع وهذا نوع من ما أركز عليه أكثر
فأنت تعلم أن الصحة العقلية كانت
تعاني ومن خلال ذلك أعتقد أنني حصلت على
فترة 10 أسابيع عندما كنت أحصل على
يومين إجازة